bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches les
missions économiques qui prend de la
hauteur jusque sur les toits de pâles
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons parler
des aides des aides aux grandes
entreprises
bonjour thomas bonjour olivier bonjour à
tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
c'est cash alors depuis le confinement
on sait l'impact économique va être
considérable les indicateurs sont au
rouge alors face à tous ces vents
contraires et pour éviter d'éventuelles
faillites ou dépôt de bilan
l'état abreuve certains secteurs dead en
tout genre et pourtant des plans sociaux
sont parfois annoncé dans des
entreprises qui perçoivent ces mêmes
aides on va donc passer en revue ses
différents dispositifs
mais on commence avec le traditionnel
tiroirs cash d'antoine basse
[Musique]
on le sait l'état n'a pas lésiné sur les
aides à apporter aux entreprises pour
faire face à la crise liée aux convives
pourtant quelques unes sortent un peu du
lot disons qu'elles ont reçu un peu plus
quoi 16 milliards pour air france
est ce un chrono débloqués en urgence au
plus fort de la crise en avril
l'état étant actionnaire de ces
entreprises à 15% pour le constructeur
auto et 14 pour la compagnie aérienne
c
sous forme de prêts garantis par l'état
que air france et renault s'engage et
évidemment à rembourser sauf s'ils
finissent en redressement judiciaire là
bas ce sera à l'état de payer la note
anouk quoi à nos impôts ces princes sont
évidemment sous conditions pas folle la
guêpe pour renault s'engager dans
l'airbus de la batterie un énorme projet
de création d'un géant européen de
batteries pour voitures électriques et
pour air france des objectifs de
rentabilité et de baisse des émissions
de co2 à mais rien sur la sauvegarde des
emplois à maman
malgré ces milliards mis sur la table
par l'état les entreprises ont déjà
enclenché des plans sociaux
pour renault la suppression de 15000
emplois dans le monde dont 4600 en
france pour air france un plan de
départs volontaires qui concernerait
autour de huy 1300 salariés autres
grands fleurons français pourfendeur
d'emplois airbus qui malgré un plan de
15 milliards pour l'aéronautique va
mettre cinq mille de ses employés
français au chômage
olivier on l'a vu dans le tiroir cash
d'antoine mahsas des aides de l'état
pour des entreprises en difficulté un
mot assez rapide sur sur scène sur ces
aides on va évidemment les détails et
dans la deuxième partie cette émission
alors ces aides c'est pas de l'argent
frais 1 c'est d'abord et avant tout des
garanties de de dette dès qu'il faudra
un moment rembourser et malheureusement
comme ce sont des entreprises qui
brassent on dirait en feuilles
permanente pour air france pour renault
il on y gagne jamais d'argent ont
finalement c'est renault s'était nissan
qui gagner de l'argent mais vu les
problèmes de carlos ghosn il ya une
espèce de scission si vous voulez entre
entre nissan et renault et je pense que
le le grands groupes intégrés dont
rêvait carlos ghosn maintenant est
terminée et donc voilà on essaie
d'entretenir un groupe qui est mourant
en le landais temps encore un petit peu
plus est avec des contreparties qu'ils
sont qui sont ridicules puisque on vous
dit il faut qu'ils rapatrient 2 2
de l'industrie en france sauf qu'ils
gagnent pas d'argent quand c'était dans
des pays à bas coûts ils vont en gagner
encore moins quand ça sera en france et
donc il faut réellement se poser la
question plutôt que à fonds perdus de
mettre des milliards et de s'apercevoir
dans trois ou quatre ans que ça n'a
servi à rien et qu'il faudra à ce
moment-là licencier tout le monde donc
il faut vraiment se poser des questions
sur une vraie politique industrielle
faire des choix et puis au lieu de
dépenser des milliards comme ça pour
rien il faudrait mieux les dépensés pour
former les gens et les reclasser
ailleurs on va passer la deuxième partie
de l'émission les vient on reçoit
aujourd'hui d'année langue économiste
maître de conférences en économie à
l'université paris xiii bonjour dany
langue merci d'être avec nous dans cette
émission de ses caches on va passer en
revue donc les différents dispositifs
dead mise en place par l'état mais
d'abord quelques indicateurs économiques
qui sont donnés par le gouvernement avec
la récession économique en france
elle devrait atteindre 11% du pib en
2020 le déficit de la france pourrait
culminer 11 4% et puis la dette publique
de notre pays 120,9 % du pib des
indicateurs très préoccupant et qui ont
donc entraîner des aides massives de
l'état d'un bilan que je voulais d'abord
avoir votre avis sur ces dispositifs
dead qui ont été mises en place par le
gouvernement ces dernières semaines
alors déjà il faut dire que ces
dispositifs dead était nécessaire les
pays qui n'ont pas fait ça vont se
trouver dans une récession encore quille
alors le moins mon souci avec ces
dispositifs c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément bénéficié à celles et ceux qui
étaient censés en bénéficier et en
particulier les pme et les pmi quand on
discutait avec des patrons pme pmi
ils sont assez nombreux ils sont pas
unanimes ils sont ainsi nombreux à vous
dire qu'ils n'ont pas eu des pleurs moi
je pense qu'il faut pas paniqué en
voyant ces indicateurs il ya une grande
partie de cette dette publique est
détenue par la banque centrale
tant que la banque centrale est garé
dans bilan il ya aucun problème de ce
côté-là je pense que c'était nécessaire
mac reims serait plutôt que maintenant
on est un retournement complet de
politique économique et qu'on se met à
faire de l'austérité ou prétexte de c2c
chiche quoi et ça ce serait extrêmement
dangereux parce que ça nous mettrait
dans une situation encore pire que celle
dans laquelle on est aidé en tableaux
mois ce qui serait assez intéressant et
qu'on oublie souvent de mon premier
c'est de regarder où en est la dette
privée parce qu'on a quand même un quart
des entreprises françaises qui risque de
déposer le bilan la suite du navire us
donc ça va ça risque de poser des
problèmes bancaires et ça risque de
causer des panique sur les marchés
financiers
donc à mon avis il faudrait aussi
présenté chiffres si on veut présenter
un tableau complet donc à mon sens la
récession grave donc elles appellent des
mesures exceptionnelles
c'est le moment ou jamais de repenser à
des mesures keynésiennes donc les
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place
était des dispositifs d'urgence
maintenant à mon sens il faut mettre en
place des dispositifs qui soit beaucoup
plus durable qu'ils soient beaucoup plus
soutenable et qu'ils soient orientés
vers des investissements publics
on a 6 ch pour faire repartir l'économie
mais aussi pour assurer d'année sa
position écologique
alors parmi les dispositifs dead qui ont
été mises en place par l'état il ya
notamment les pge les prêts garantis par
l'état qui sont destinés aux entreprises
qui peuvent représenter jusqu'au quart
de leur chiffre d'affaires de 2019 ils
sont garantis à hauteur de 70 à 90% par
l'état et l'enveloppent prévu est autour
de 300 milliards d'euros et parmi les
bénéficiaires il ya le secteur de la
construction qui représente un quart des
sommes garanties suivi de l'industrie
manufacturière
olivier qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
dispositif de ce moyen d'aider les
entreprises par des prêts
et dont l'état se porte garant mais
c'est pas un moyen d'aider les
entreprises
c'est un moyen de les endettés et donc
en fait quelque part de l'est de les
acheter
je vous avais dit à quelques il ya
quelques semaines on était rentrés dans
une période de deux semaines et isation
de l'économie c'est à ça qu'on assiste
c'est à dire que on endette des
entreprises qui sont déjà pour la
plupart déjà pas mal endettés et quand
vous êtes endettés et quand vous êtes
surendetté en plus vous appartenez à qui
vous appartenez à votre créancier donc
fin de l'histoire
et comme celle est à oublier le
créancier au final puisqu'il garantit
ses prêts eh bien vous appartenait à
l'état lundi l'entreprise dont l'état
est déjà actionnaire et qui sont parfois
si ce n'est des fleurons en tout cas des
entreprises importantes pour la france
on pense à air france à airbus on va
évidemment revenir sur ces entreprises
est ce qu'il est nécessaire quand même
que l'état vienne en aide à ses
entreprises
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
olivier delamarche le moi ce qui
m'inquiète vraiment ces niveaux
d'endettement privé et donc on contribue
se faisant alors nettement privé et pour
un certain nombre d'entreprises ça peut
justifier le et d'ailleurs et un certain
nombre de pme qui n'ont pas eu accès aux
prêts garantis par l'état parce que
quand faut-il rappeler que ça passe par
les banques et que les banques
commencent à sentir le vent du boulet et
donc il ya un certain nombre
d'entreprises ces mêmes soldats qui
n'ont pas eu accès à ces crèches donc
pour moi c'est pas du tout nous ceux des
tees à sion d'économie c'est pas ça dont
il est question et certainement pas avec
le gouvernement pennies avant mais par
contre je suis d'accord avec olivier
delamarche pour dire que le niveau de
dette privée est inquiétant ne s'était
pas forcément dans des fonds
supplémentaires dont on avait besoin
alors on l'a vu en première partie de
cette émission le problème qui se pose
avec certains de ses plans dead et bien
c'est qu'il coïncide aussi avec des
plans de restructuration va prendre
l'exemple d'air france pour commencer
7 milliards d'euros des dons été apporté
4 milliard de prêts bancaires garantis
et 3 milliards de prêts directs pour air
france klm
même les pays-bas promettent une aide de
3 4 milliards d'euros pour soutenir la
compagnie nationale et puis donc le plan
de reconstruction en d'air france klm
7500 suppressions de postes était
envisagée d'ici fin 2022 6560 des 41
mille salariés au sein de la compagnie
dont bill pardon au sein de la compagnie
régionale up et environ 3500 départs
naturels non remplacés
olivier lorsqu'on vient en aide comme ça
une entreprise est ce qu'on peut lui
demander des garanties sur l'emploi
la semblablement ça n'a pas été le cas
pour le plan daide auprès de air france
klm
bon enfin oui bien sûr que vous pouvez
lui demander mais ça réglera pas le
problème le le souci sur sur air france
comme sûrs d'ailleurs beaucoup de
compagnies aériennes c'est que c'est
perdre c'est que c'est perdu
actuellement en faillite donc tous les
cinq ans en gros vous avez un pépin qui
fait que la la compagnie aérienne étant
est en faillite donc vous entretenez
quelque chose qui qui était à l'agonie
depuis très longtemps parce que des
coûts très importants par rapport même à
d'autres compagnies parce que
concurrence en interne sur avec la sncf
parce que plein de ligne qui ne sont
absolument pas rentable parce que tu as
donc vous pouvez vous pouvez injecter
autant d'argent que vous voulez d'abord
vous le reverrez jamais et secundo dans
je vous fais les paris que dans cinq ou
six ans on va recommencer
manille langue est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ce constat je suis en
partie d'accord avec ce constat et en
particulier moi ce qui m'interpelle
beaucoup c'est que l'on maintienne les
lignes
qui font concurrence à la sncf alors que
le train est quand même un moyen
beaucoup moins polluant de se déplacer à
mon sens enfin ça ne choque quand même
assez en général qu'on donne des aides
publiques et puis dans suite derrière il
ya des licenciements
ceci étant dit c'est une situation
exceptionnelle
là on peut pas obliger ces entreprises à
garder leurs salariés à mon sens il
vaudrait mieux contraindre enfin créer
un dispositif pour tous les des
personnes qui vont être licenciés et qui
risquent de se retrouver sans
perspective et sans moyens donc de faire
face à leurs différents des sciences moi
ça fait longtemps que je soutiens l'idée
d' emploi garanti
ça permettrait on va pas obliger les
entreprises dans le contexte actuel à
garder leurs salariés ça n'a pas de sens
à mon sens il vaudrait mieux avoir un
emploi garanti peut me proposer le
thunder sous tome 2 propose mais son
homologue et collègues des américains
c'est à dire on propose un emploi
toutes ces personnes en attendant
qu'elles retrouvent un autre job dans le
privé une dent mais si on va marquer une
courte pause on revient dans quelques
instants pour continuer à parler de ces
dispositifs des deux lancés par l'état
on a notamment parlé de renault de
retour dans ces caches on parle des
aides de l'état aux grandes entreprises
françaises et qui coïncide parfois avec
des plans de restructurations nettes
avec olivier delamarche évidemment mais
aussi avec dany langue économiste maître
de conférences en économie à
l'université paris 13 ans par les
messieurs des aides d'état qui coïncide
donc avec des plans sociaux notamment
donc au sein de airbus dont on va parler
maintenant l'état rallonger l'aide
pendant un an à airbus le coût de cette
mesure c'est environ
c'est plus d'un milliard d'euros même
selon le ministère de l'économie et des
finances et pourtant l'avionneur
européen a annoncé mardi 30 juin un
vaste plan social dans le monde
comprenant notamment cinq mille
suppressions d'emplois en france là
encore on a un peu le même exemple que
précédemment avec air france c'est ce
que vous comprenez olivier 7 ce plan
social de la part d'airbus qui avait des
carnets de commandes qui semble-t-il
était plutôt plein avant le confinement
qui ont
imagine aujourd'hui sont un peu plus
vide hamas qui est très drôle c'est que
il ya quelques mois encore on regardait
de haut boeing en disant ils ont plus de
comment nous on en a beaucoup on est les
meilleurs
beau et on nous vend des airbus comme la
grande réussite européenne et et
quelques mois plus tard patatras qu il
ya plus personne donc le le problème je
vous dis c'est que on entretient en fait
des boîtes alors pas forcément pour
airbus mais sur sur air france on l'a on
va le voir aussi sur renault qui sur
lequel il faut vraiment s'interroger sur
le sur le modèle est pas et pas
simplement remettre des sous à chaque
fois qu'ils tendent la main donc parce
que ça ne sert à rien et parce que vous
arriverez au bout du bout par des
licenciements massifs et par une
fermeture de la société donc posons nous
les questions avant et et faisons en
sorte que les salariés que ce soit de
renault ou d'air france soient reclassés
ailleurs dans de bonnes conditions
continuent à être payés plutôt que deux
je vous dis de mettre des sous dans un
dans un puits sans fond ce qu'il paraît
pas forcément intelligent parce que vous
arriverez de toute façon dans cinq six
ans vous arriverez exactement au même
résultat sur air france je refais mon
pari mais vous verrez que dans cinq ans
ou redonnera de l'argent à air france et
que comme si de rien n'était comme si
rien ne s'était passé
on va redonner de l'argent à air france
on va redonner de l'argent à reno dans
dans trois quatre ans cinq ans et et ça
n'en finit plus donc posons nous les
bonnes questions ni langue avant de
parler de renault un mot sur ces
entreprises est ce que leur fragilité
était déjà là en fait avant le
confinement est ce que finalement ça n'a
pas servi uniquement de révélateur à une
mauvaise santé économique pour certaines
de ces entreprises
non ça dépend de quelle entreprise on
parle
1 - sens 1 et airbus comme la réussite
européenne d'ailleurs parce que c'est la
seule
donc effectivement leur carnet de
commandes était plein je pense
qu'effectivement il ya des structures
est certain nombre de grandes
entreprises et que l'argent qui a été
mis par l'état aurait-il dans la
transition écologique ou dans une espèce
qui n'ont pas garanti dans dans le
secteur public et en particulier à
l'hôpital et d'universités qui sont à
l'agonie
donc à mon sens ça fait beaucoup
puissance que de mettre de l'argent dans
des secteurs qui sont publiques par
nature que dans des secteurs qui
relèvent du privé
donc effectivement je partage l'idée de
la marge consistant à dire que dans
quelques années on va on va encore
mettre au pot sur les français et
d'autres sociétés renault en particulier
jeu pour airbus plus mitigé parce que là
c'est vraiment laissé du président et
oui c'est la seule réussite européenne
attendre parce que c'est bien la seule
on va parler maintenant déjà de renault
messieurs si vous voulez bien puisque là
aussi l'état apporté un soutien
financier assez important 5 milliards
d'euros et puis dans le même temps un
plan d'économies de l'entreprise
française 4600 emplois supprimés en
france quinze mille au total dans le
monde olivier est ce que l'état
je vous repose la question mais on
imagine que ces suppressions d'emplois
qui coïncide avec des aides de l'état
cela peut choquer l'opinion puisque on
donne de l'argent à une entreprise qui
derrière suppriment des emplois alors
l'état dit que c'est aussi pour
justement cette transition écologique
comme on l'a vu dans le tiroir cage
d'antoine wasa ce qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ça mais n'ont même pas la
sueur sur renault je vais revenir sur
votre question de d'avant c'était dire
est ce que finalement le le vide n'a pas
été qu'un révélateur
bien sûr que si alors sur renault c'est
très clair renault avait des difficultés
avant le vide et et le
le le fait d'avoir en france deux
acteurs qui sont exactement sur les
mêmes gammes c'est-à-dire moyenne et bas
de gamme où on sait très bien qu'on ne
gagne pas d'argent qui n'ont absolument
pas pris de virages quels qu'ils soient
sur sur le les voitures électriques ou
une alternative en tout cas au diesel
qui était la grande force des véhicules
français
enfin la soi-disant grande force on a
fait on a mis le paquet sur le sur le
diesel on s'est aperçu maintenant que le
diesel polluer plus fin
on a on n'a aucune vision aucune
et ça c'est malheureusement dans tous
les domaines la seule vision que les
politiques c'est à cinq ans c'est-à-dire
leur réélection mais le reste il n'y a
aucune vision est donc dans les groupes
dans certains grands groupes c'est la
même chose et on a là aujourd'hui je
vous dis deux acteurs qui sont
exactement sur le même créneau il en a
pas y en a pas un qui est sur le haut de
gamme et l'autre sur le sueur
bas de gamme et moyenne gamme et donc il
faut se poser la question est ce qu on a
deux acteurs majeurs comme ça à avoir en
france
c'est là c'est la question à se poser
est ce que par hasard on ne pourrait pas
en faire évoluer un ou même se poser la
question d'en faire disparaître un ça
augmenterait très probablement les
chances du deuxième de d'exister sans
avoir besoin de l'aide massive de l'état
c'est à dire de nous en fait
au final quand vous achetez une renault
vous la payer deux fois dans vos impôts
et quand vous faites le chèque à la
concession
lundi donc lorsque l'état engage autant
d'argent pour aider une entreprise en
l'occurrence 5 milliards pour renault il
est pas en mesure vraiment demandé des
garanties sur l'emploi on voit qu'il a
demandé des garanties sur la transition
écologique sur la construction d'une
batterie électrique pour voilà la
transition écologique de l'eau de
l'automobile mais il n'est pas en mesure
de demander à ce que des emplois soient
sauvegardés dans une période si à des
fils ils pour pour les français
effectivement normalement quand sinon
sud entreprises à hauteur de plusieurs
milliards on est en droit d'exiger des
contreparties en matière d'emploi
mais ça l'état ne l'a jamais fait et
depuis des années des années on est des
entreprises à s'installer sur un
territoire
elles prennent l'argent et qui après
elles s'en vont donc est-ce que cet
argent ne serait pas mieux
justement ont utilisé dans la transition
écologique dans la reconversion aussi de
toutes ces personnes qui vont se
retrouver sur le carreau
à mon avis si à mon avis y est je suis
d'accord avec olivier delamarche pour
dire que deux acteurs qui font du bas de
gamme de l'entrée de gamme moyenne gamme
c'est trop il en faut un en france
alors ce sera un monopole mais ce sera
un monopole mais si les gens aux
finances par l'état ça peut être un
monopole et dans faut un est un acteur
qui monte en gamme merci beaucoup dany
lang d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
que vous êtes économiste maître de
conférences en économie à l'université
paris xiii on passe pour ce qui nous
concerne aux questions cash
on passe aux questions cash
olivier première question signé jacob
abel je me demande pourquoi nous n'avons
pas pensé à placer une taxe sur les
produits anglais suite à la crise de la
vache folle je me demande pourquoi nous
n'avons pas pensé à placer une taxe sur
les produits américains à la suite d
crise des 'subprimes' cela nous aurait
permis de financer indemnisés et ces les
dégâts on comprend en filigrane la
question de la responsabilité du pays
plus ou moins à l'origine de la crise
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette idée
et on va instaurer une taxe sur
l'incompétence de nos dirigeants
parce que ça nous permettrait aussi de
rembourser dans les bêtises qu'ils ont
fait
donc pas de vous n'êtes pas trop
d'accord sur cette piste de réflexion de
taxer en l'occurrence et ses caisses que
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que à chaque fois que il va se passer
quelque chose on va aller chercher
savoir si par hasard il n'ya pas d'où ça
vient enfin s'il n'y a pas un coupable
c'est toujours la même chose
c'est-à-dire que l'on cherche des
coupables à l'extérieur alors que les
principaux coupables c'est à l'intérieur
qu'il faut aller les chercher
c'est la mauvaise gestion on a depuis
des années et c'est pas il faut pas
mettre tout sur le dos du coc vide donc
qui est ce que vous allez taxer pour ça
mais pas tout sur le dos du pangolin on
aura bien compris autre question signé
roland lucile bonjour olivier le modèle
de décroissance prônée par certains
écologistes est il compatible avec notre
modèle économique productiviste on pense
évidemment à cette vague verte telle
qu'elle est parfois présenté aux
élections municipales
on vous savez là la vague verte des
municipales ça me fait penser un peu aux
fonds vert du cinéma c'est à dire que
vous collez ce que vous voulez tuer
vous avez des gens qui certains les
appellent les pastèques vous savez vert
à l'extérieur rouge à l'intérieur
la vague verte je sais pas très bien à
quoi ça correspond et ils sont plus
écologiste dans l'eure dans leurs
discours que qu'en réalité donc avec nos
modèles de décroissance je crois pas que
ce soit un modèle de décroissance qui
failli auquel il fallait y penser c'est
un modèle de croissance molle faible et
il va falloir s'y adapter c'est tout
mais on peut pas prôner un modèle de
décroissance ça veut rien dire merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir suivi
cette émission vous pouvez retrouver les
émissions précédentes sur le site rtl
france point tv n'oubliez pas de poser
vos questions dans la section
commentaires ou sur les réseaux sociaux
avec le hashtag rt cash
olivier le maux de l'afrique on a écouté
des sous un joug gourde et sutout jours